[Music]
[Music]
uh
three two one
[Music]
he's gonna hit the ground there
[Music]
into the side he's gonna fall down and
get him down simple are you serious
what is that you can't do that simple
that's not allowed this is not fpl
this is a major
[Music]
sniper rifles are objects of worship in
just about every game they're in
doesn't matter what you play everybody
wants to use the sniper rifle
and guys i was watching this kid he has
some of the nastiest headshots in the
game as you see him going to work
he's got kind of a twitch shot there's
the double kill
oh man there's the triple show me the
overkill soldier hell it's the gun's so
good that millions of kids in halo 3
turn to
team killing just to get their hands on
that sweet
sweet scope if you've played any first
person shooter some 14 year old sniper
has made you want to throw your headset
out the window whether it's because
they're on the enemy team and they're
farming you on repeat
or because they're on your team and they
keep dying and spawn
all of us had a sniper rifle phase don't
deny it you
like me at one point thought that you
could be the biggest baddest sniper on
the server
most of us have outgrown that dream
because we realize that we don't have
the skills to cut it
but we still revere snipers
so why why are sniper rifles so
goddamn cool to answer that question we
have to go way back to 2009
when a classic bless the shelves of your
local game store
call of duty modern warfare 2.
sniping has always been a big part of
cod but with modern warfare 2
it became a part of the series dna all
thanks to a guy called
zur grins who made sniping montages huge
on youtube i mean if you get your hair
your or if you get like
uh 579 which a lot of people use and
you know you get your pred missile you
get your harrier grizz is the godfather
of cod sniping
he was the game's first big content
creator and if you have a favorite cod
personality these days
chances are that back in the day they
were inspired by grizz's montages
oh it's grizz grizz i'm a big fan chris
no way this is how i see grizz he is the
godfather of youtube in my mind
but it wasn't until modern warfare 2
that a lot of these folks turned their
idolization
into inspiration and picked up a capture
card to make their
own videos enter optic gaming and phase
clan
optic and phases sniping montages and
clips racked up hundreds of thousands
of views on youtube back in 2010
something that was insane
at the time they turned sniping into an
art the map was their canvas and the
sniper rifle was their paintbrush
they realized that getting kills wasn't
worth it if you didn't look cool while
doing it
and the only way to make the impossible
possible was to equip the intervention
and spend the next five hours spinning
around the map like a beyblade until you
got the trick shot
the appeal also comes from their sheer
power
sniper rifles are deadly they're defined
by incredible range and incredible
damage
which means that even one bullet can
turn the most hopeless situation around
players like sniper rifles because they
make them feel powerful
to hold a sniper rifle is to hold a life
and death in your hands
if you're a pleb you miss and you die
but if you're a god
you hit your shots and you dominate the
server from afar becoming completely
untouchable and no game illustrates a
sniper's ability to take over a match
better
than counter-strike krimz able to take
down glaive and it's on to device by the
truck he's being pressured from so many
sides
still able to find the frag on today jw
is the bomb
looking to get down but golden wants
another frag we'll find it onto zip x
it's all on to device first no scope and
the second device
the clutch the 2v1 on that a bomb site
there's a lot that goes into what gun
you choose to buy
in cs go power efficiency accuracy
but every gun comes with a risk because
the better a gun is
the more expensive it usually is and the
more expensive a gun is
the more it sucks when you die without
getting a kill and hand it over to your
phone
and the op carries the ultimate risk
he's little backs away man it's dead all
the shots that he desperately needed and
he needed the other one as well in
between
both times and he's off in time and get
rights found he's a sitting duck it's
all gone
so many opportunities and he just
couldn't find the shots he needed
the op is one of the most expensive guns
in the game but it's also one of the
most powerful
and it's one of the hardest to use i
think it's a mix
of two things first of all it's a high
risk high reward weapon
if you miss you might lose the round
because you the other team gets drowned
and you will be
foreigners and it's really bad gun to
retake so you really need
to not miss your shots so you
your aim is really important and second
your decision making
is probably the it has to be really
really sharp
since csgo came out in 2012 the op has
been nerfed plenty of times
most famously in 2015 when valve reduced
a movement speed of operas while they
were scoped in
but the best of the best adapted zywu
device
kenny s there's a reason why the best
player on a team
is usually the primary opera there's a
lot of responsibility that comes with
wielding the op
mess up once and you not just screw over
your team's economy you also hand over
one of the best guns in the game to your
enemy but forest is there to put it back
on the deck miss shot dragon
they now know he's out toward the
chicken coop but he's got problems
because they're flooding in oh draken
no dragon that's three sitting in front
of his crosstalk he misses the flick as
well this could be the round
because they've gotten get right they've
gotten a gun in fact it's just down to
exist and draken could have controlled
that on his own but there's a reason
people are willing to stake their
reputation on the op
it can take over a game quickly falling
apart here navi getting a bit scary but
then guardian has something to say about
that takes out the kill on apex that was
on argent
wow what a shot on the rpk gets the
blink on the maniac
[Applause]
what a monster in cs go you only get one
life around which means seconds into
that round
a good opera can instantly turn a 5v5
into a 4v5
and that can be huge if you could just
become nutty with the off like the pros
you would cruise your way to global
elite and that thought has inspired
silver players
everywhere to pick up the op as soon as
they have the money in reality though
most players never reach that level but
that only makes sniping cooler
there's a level of elitism that comes
with the op it's reserved for only the
best
he ends up just getting humiliated
staring at the wall kenny he's looking
for more and this is phenomenal stuff
holding the wolf from the door with an
orp of all weapons
he finds another one man he's he's
already gone above and beyond
flashes looks like he wants some more
rops is on those close boxes he does
drop
in and kenny he's doing it all it's
kidding yes
baby we're amazed when someone gets a 4k
in cs go with the op because we know the
difficulty involved in managing your
precision and reaction time while
enemies run around obscuring your vision
with utility it's power and sex appeal
sure
but it's also the skill of doing
something incredibly difficult
and they're going to be mading off and
jw of course lands the first shot
they're going to be fully aware
but some game sniper rifles don't have
that going for them and when the skill
threshold goes wrong
it can really mess with a game take the
operator
the sniper rifle in riot games tactical
shooter valerie
since the beta the op was arguably the
most oppressive gun in the game
when you combined it with jet's movement
abilities and the fact that there was
very little good utility to throw at it
it was pretty easy to call it
overpowered i thought the involunt
initially the gun wasn't
really strong really really strong
especially because you could shoot
jumping and the accuracy was um instant
like you hit the ground and you could
shoot instantly that was
insane for jets especially i don't think
it is broken though
as the months went on and the operator
dominated both pro and ranked play
sniping and valorem began to lose its
luster first of all
some said that it was easier to master
valorance operator than csgo's op
which made godly sniping skills a lot
less impressive but more importantly the
constant christ in nerf the gun made
truly incredible plays from guys like
wardell and mixwell
less exciting in september the fans got
their wish
the operator was gutted to the point
where some players were asking if
sniping was even worth it anymore i
don't think it is that strong anymore i
think
they went too far gun is too expensive i
think a lot of teams will play with five
rifles and no operators especially on
attack
and some of the players that play it a
lot like wardell
will have to start playing rifle more
because i don't think it's really
valuable in some maps attacking before
because really skilled players could get
away with anything
you could play attacking now i don't
think you can and we will have to adapt
to the new changes
that nerf may have impacted sniping and
valorent for a long time
and that can affect how people view the
game what does a competitive shooter
look like when sniping isn't the sexiest
highest skill thing you can be doing
it's hard to say in a lot of ways the
ops issues are proof that
our love for sniper rifles isn't just
about the guns themselves
it's about the reasons we fell in love
with esports to begin with
we love watching the pros elevate their
game into an art form
hitting chance that 99.9 of players
could never even dream of hitting
sometimes it makes us feel like they're
gods of the game that we play too
sometimes it makes us want to hit those
shots too
because whether it's a crazy trick shot
and cod or a 1v5 clutch in cs go
sniping is the ultimate form of skill
expression in first person shooters
and there is nothing cooler than being
the best
[Applause]
we have been getting audio this whole
time right god thank god holy [ __ ] i got
so scared thinking i didn't have audio
and there is nothing cooler than being
the best
okay we're done i hope we're done this
time i hope it's actually done
it better be done it's been recording
this whole time
it's recorded for 22 minutes if it
didn't record
if there wasn't audio i'm gonna screen